herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge
ein Tag persönlicher Koch endlich mal
wieder heute ist aber alles anders denn
ich koche nicht ganz einfach sondern
10000 Kalorien und die kann ich nicht
alleine essen sondern ich brauche jemand
der darin Erfahrung hat und deshalb habe
ich Franklin eingeladen mein lieber du
bist eine Maschine 10.000 Kalorien
20.000 Kalorien alles schon gegessen
hier stehen schon die Zutaten des
Frühstück the rock French Toast oh ja
das ist so real Talk mein lieblings von
allen frühstücken die man essen kann
gerade bei so einem Cheat day ich weiß
auf jeden Fall wenn es gut machst dann
wird das ein richtiger Restaurant ich
leg mich ins Zeug machst du dir jetzt
bequem und wir gehen an die Arbeit
beginnen wir mit dem Zutaten ein
gesamter briochtopf vier Eier Zucker
brauner Zucker Zimt Milch eine Prise
Salz Erdnussbutter Ahornsirup
Puderzucker Vanille und Sahne also
eigentlich alles was hier steht hat
viele Kalorien insgesamt
ist das schon eine ziemliche Bombe zum
Frühstück Besonderheit bei den the rock
French Toast ist dass sie so schön dick
bleiben deshalb müssen sie ein bisschen
aufsaugen ich habe mir schon was
überlegt wie wir nachhelfen das auch
wirklich überall in diesem Brioche diese
French Toast Mischung ist als
allererstes Eier aufschlagen Prise Salz
Vanilleextrakt und die Milch natürlich
Vollmilch jetzt verquirlen wir das alles
also ordentlich hier schön drehen und
man sieht direkt das saugt sich sehr
sehr schön voll ich habe einen Trick
Frank der hat gesagt er hat sich die
Dinger schon häufiger selbst gemacht und
rein logisch finde ich kann die
Flüssigkeit ja nur mit Zeit in die Mitte
ziehen das funktioniert bestimmt auch
gut ich habe hier aber so eine
quetschflasche mit der ich jetzt ein
bisschen von unserer Flüssigkeit einfach
in das Brioche Brot reinspritzen werde
und euch das mal an ich fühle das hier
jetzt richtig schön auf mit unserer
French Toast Flüssigkeit einfach in die
Mitte rein ich glaube wir sind da
einer guten Sache auf der Fährte hatten
wir uns jetzt eine Fahne stellen sie auf
den Herd bei mittlerer Hitze kann schon
mal langsam warm werden bisschen Butter
50 Gramm und wenn wir hier drüben bei
dem French Toast mal gucken von der
Flüssigkeit die wir am Anfang hatten ist
wirklich nicht mehr so viel übrig es
wird jetzt Zeit unsere French Toast in
die Pfanne zu geben in unsere Butter wo
wir sie jetzt langsam goldbraun braten
von allen Seiten die jetzt hier oben
wirklich schon eine schön geschlossene
Schicht unten ist auch fertig jetzt
braten wir das von allen Seiten noch
einmal an und dann steht dem perfekten
French Toast nichts mehr im Weg so geht
das ganze jetzt bei 100 Grad in den Ofen
für 10 15 Minuten so dass es durch
erhitzt wird weiter geht's mit der Soße
für die Soße brauchen wir Ahornsirup
Kokosmilch und Erdnussbutter alle drei
Sachen haben richtig viel Kalorien die
gebe ich einfach in meine Schüssel und
verrühre sie dann mit einem Schneebesen
zu einer himmlischen Masse zwei Dinge
fehlen nur für unser Topping einmal
Kokos-Chips einfach in der Pfanne kurz
angepostet die geben uns den Crunch
später und eine Schlagsahne Puderzucker
weil klar nicht schon süß genug ist und
eine Vanilleschote schön in der Mitte
halbieren jetzt das ganze einfach schön
steif schlagen perfekte Sahne konsi ist
erreicht noch mal kalt stellen und dann
gleich servieren
[Musik]
Rock French Toast und das ganze Top ist
jetzt noch frisch für dich mit einer
Nocke Sahne pro French Toast auch krank
zu glauben ist dass das jetzt über 4000
Kalorien hat
eingeblendet ich glaube das hat
vielleicht hat sogar 5000 Kalorien aber
ich esse wahrscheinlich ein Franken ist
drei weil ich kann nicht so viel essen
ich weiß gar nicht wie du das machst du
kennst das ja ne du hast ja auch schon
die ein oder andere Folge 4k gesehen ja
probieren Pokerface kleine erste
Einschätzung vielleicht und dann reden
wir darüber wie es wirklich schwierig
aber ich werde mein Profil auflegen
guten Appetit guten Appetit
ich finde die Konsistenz dieses
matschiges sehr nice und auch die Kokos
Chips sind echt wichtig dass man so ein
bisschen Crunch drin hat ein bisschen
was wo der Zahn sich so fangen kann ich
bin Loki satt es schmeckt jetzt noch
geiler als alles Frühstück ist die erste
Mahlzeit des Tages da kommt natürlich
noch viele Faktoren dazu aber sagen an
dem Punkt
wir sehen uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
ich kann nicht verstehen wie du jetzt
gerade noch weiter essen kannst ich habe
eins und ein bisschen gegessen und du
verdrückst gerade Nummer drei und
wirklich mir geht's schon bisschen
schlecht
mir geht's so ein bisschen zu bisschen
besser
weggeputzt ich kann nur so viel sagen es
ist unfassbar lecker jetzt frage ich
mich aber wie schneidet er the rock
French Toast ab das ist einfach eine 10
von 10 weil das ist wirklich das ist
mein Lieblingsmenü so
du hast das erste Mal heute gemacht das
ist richtig krass abgeliefert aber ich
habe das auch gefühlt in meinem Herzen
und genauso werde ich die nächsten
Speisen führen machen wir weiter mit dem
Mittagessen das hat absolute
Smash Burger mit Mac das ist was ist
jetzt geht ganz leichtes Rezept das
Beste von euch Top mit Ellbogen Film
ganz wichtig dass es die sind so um die
Ecke gehen und jetzt fühlen wir das
Ganze bis zur naturlichen föhnlinie mit
kochendem Wasser das ganze salzig jetzt
und lass es so lange kochen bis das
ganze Wasser entweder eingezogen oder
verkocht ist dann gebe ich die gleiche
Menge Käse und Kondensmilch dazu und das
ist alles was ich für die perfekten Mac
and cheese tun muss hier drüben haben
wir extra dick geschnitten den lassen
wir jetzt auf unserem Blech im Backofen
schön aus der braucht noch 20 5 Minuten
Zeit deshalb wichtig dass direkt zu
Beginn zu machen natürlich halten wir es
nicht ganz so simpel bei unserem Smash
Burger wir wollen richtig auf die Kacke
hauen deshalb mache ich noch
karamellisierte Zwiebeln dazu und
ordentlicher Ecke Futter machen wir mal
50 km rein geben wir eine fein
geschnittene Zwiebel die Nudeln sind
gekocht Wasser ist weg jetzt geben wir
die Kondensmilch drüber und zur
Kondensmilch frisch geriebener Käse und
wenn es später zu trocken sein sollte
gehen wir einfach ein Stückchen Milch
oder Wasser hinzu und Kriegen diese
tolle
Feuchtigkeit mama mia einfach
wunderschön der hat so viel Fett
verloren da wir hier eine Kalorien
Challenge machen werden wir das
logischerweise nicht einfach wegschütten
oder so sondern zu unseren
karamellisierten Zwiebeln hinzufügen
eigentlich war der Plan den auf den
Burger zu bekommen aber er war sogar zu
dick geschnitten deshalb bin jetzt ein
bisschen klein schneiden werden und dann
in die Mac and cheese einarbeiten alles
ist vorbereitet
karamellisierte Zwiebeln mit Bacon Fett
sechs Kugel drin Fleisch bereit zum
smashion angetastete BR gespannt Ketchup
Mario und Bacon für das allererstes mal
die banks mit Mario bestreichen die
Unterseite mit Mayo auch hier natürlich
nicht zu knapp wir sind immer noch in
der Kalorien Challenge kennt das
mittlerweile
Rindfleisch natürlich würzen das ganze
Salz und Pfeffer und Leute drei Patties
drei Scheiben Käse wow das sind einige
Kalorien jetzt müssen wir noch mal die
Makkaroni fertigstellen wir sind jetzt
schon so ein bisschen angetrocknet wie
gesagt ganz einfach bisschen Wasser
hinzugeben gehen wir hier drüben
karamellisierten Zwiebeln und Topf so
klingen gute Mac and cheese und jetzt
kommt der Bacon hinein wir Grünen
unseren König und richten an ich hoffe
du bist bereit was kommt
ist wirklich unglaublich zwei Triple
Smash Burger mit bisschen über einem
halben Kilo Mac and cheese mit Bacon
dazu ein schönes Bierchen das schaut für
mich jetzt also dass das Frühstück ist
wirklich noch easy oder so
entspannt es mir aber das schaut für
mich jetzt wirklich ja wie so ein
Wettessen so krank ausgeben rein oder
wie viel Kalorien
gibt's
auch okay ich glaube für meinen Teil
brauche ich auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
Hilfe
[Musik]
alter Schwede ich habe nicht an uns
geglaubt oder nicht an Dich geglaubt
dass du das noch geschafft hast Respekt
ich werde jetzt noch nicht die Menge
deswegen kriegen die making cheese von
mir eine sieben von zehn okay also ich
kann es verstehen ich habe mich ja auch
für die Mac and Chees entschieden aus
dieser Kalorien Perspektive die haben ja
ordentlich Kalorien auch ich dachte mir
eine Beilage brauchen wir die reinhaut
und ich muss sagen der Burger hat geil
geschmeckt die Konsistenz die die Bank
und sowas sehr sehr nice das Fleisch
hatte schön den Crunch war auf dem Punkt
allerdings habe ich das tatsächlich die
Mario doch echt gestört und zwar ich
habe von dem Fleisch nicht so viel
rausgeschmeckt weil einfach die Mayo so
beiß drauf Mario Zunge deswegen kriegt
der Burger von mir 8,5 von 10 insgesamt
würde ich den Gericht eine 8 von 10
geben weil einfach der Burger doch
stärker geworden hat also acht von zehn
will ich mich nicht beschweren schau mal
wie das Abendessen wird davor erstmal
ein bisschen durchschnaufen ich muss ein
bisschen was vorbereiten Franklin geht
ins Gym damit er wieder Kraft hat und
Power hat und wir sehen uns gleich in
der Küche kommen wir zum Abendessen wir
machen eine Kurien Barbecue chicken
Pizza mit cheesy Cross es klingt wieder
nach Kalorien es klingt wieder lecker
und genau das wollen wir auch schaffen
Pizzateig ist der vom letzten Video die
beste Pizza die du zu Hause machen
kannst aber wir backen heute im
Pizzaofen so dass es noch mal eine
Schippe krasser wird also los geht's 12g
Hefe gebe ich in 400 ml lauwarmes Wasser
in Hefe aufgelöst ist geben wir unseren
Zucker dazu und unser Olivenöl jetzt
können wir in unsere Rührschüssel das
Mehl geben dann das Salz dazu
unter und dann gehen wir nach und nach
die Flüssigkeit dazu nach wenigen
Minuten sieht das ganze so aus und lösen
wir es einmal ab und geben das Ganze zum
finalen durchkneten auf unser blockboard
lange nicht Bewerbung für Block gemacht
unsere Pizza ein bisschen größer sein
wir klappen mir dann den Krustenanteil
wieder ein also Behälter ordentlich
Dritteln wir das ganze einzelne Kugeln
nach innen falten das ist schön
geschlossen sind wie der Teig machen
habt ihr schon ein paar mal gesehen auch
wie wir die Soße machen alles drum und
dran weil dieser Pizza kommt es vor
allem auf die Toppings an und um die
kümmern wir uns jetzt wir nehmen uns
hähnchenkoteletts und schneiden sie in
chicken gerechte Größen das Beste ist
für die Marinade brauchen wir nur
geriebenen Ingwer etwas Öl Pfeffer und
Salz jetzt das Ganze gut durchkneten und
marinieren lassen das wird unser korin
Fried Chicken ist mariniert jetzt müssen
wir nur noch panieren und das koreen
Fried Chicken ist machen wir das in
Stärke und Backpulver stärker rein
Backpulver rein bisschen Salz noch dazu
dann kann auch schon das Chicken Folgen
irgendwas jetzt schön eingezogen und die
Aromen gehen wir einmal drauf und jetzt
können wir unser paniertes checken ins
Öl geben vom Körper weg den ganzen ein
bisschen Farbe bekommen
wir jetzt zur Königsdisziplin jetzt
Formen wir unsere Pizza der Pizzaofen
heizt schon vor nehmen wir den Teig
jetzt auf die semola zack kommt perfekt
raus schön geschlossen und unten jetzt
können wir schon anfangen den Teig zu
formen einfach durch die Hände gleiten
lassen der wird sich von selbst in die
Länge ziehen wollen müssen gucken dass
er ein bisschen größer ist als bei einer
normalen Pizza wir brauchen ja Platz für
unsere cheesy crust Rand ein bisschen
platt drücken dann habe ich hier jetzt
Provolone Käse den ich einfach so ein
bisschen halbieren werde und einmal
schön für den Rand auslege echt wichtig
dass das luftdicht geschlossen ist beim
Rand weil sonst läuft uns ja einfach die
cheesy krass auf die Pizza drauf ich
habe sogar schon ein bisschen Hunger
wieder weil ich habe ja auch lange nicht
so viel gegessen wie Franken also jetzt
Tomatensoße drauf Mozzarella drüber der
großen Moment
so bleiben wir die Pizza jetzt in den
Ofen und hoffen aufs beste also Leute
drückt mir die Daumen die größte Pizza
die hier gebacken habe ist jetzt im Ofen
aber das hier ist unsere Pizza und die
kann sich wie ich finde sehen lassen es
wird Zeit wir haben extra noch bis
gerade gewartet damit es nicht nass wird
oder so dass wir unser chicken einmal in
unserem Glace geben von allen Seiten
schön bedecken wir mit ein bisschen
Sesam dran jetzt gehen wir chicken drauf
so ungefähr zwei Drittel von dem was wir
gemacht haben das sind wirklich
ordentliche chicken hier noch mal kurz
reingeben
jetzt schneide ich ein paar
Frühlingszwiebeln und diese asiatische
Variante mit aufzunehmen
das Chicken ist heiß die Pizza ist groß
und zu guter Letzt die Barbecue source
einmal drüber
Frühlingszwiebeln für den Farbkontrast
da sind wir wieder schön beim food porn
dann bringen wir mal rüber
[Musik]
der sich schön aufzieht guten Appetit
Leute
lassen das Ding jetzt auf und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
auch die letzte Schlacht wurde
geschlagen Franklin wir haben es
geschafft gemeinsam über 10.000 Kalorien
die genaue Zahl sind die eingeblendet
weil die justieren das genau dass Sie
auch wirklich wisst was hier auf den
Tellern stand Digger also das zweite
Stück ich habe es noch mal gefaltet und
da man wirklich gemerkt dass es was
ausmacht und welche Reihenfolge die
Sachen auf die Zunge kommen weil einfach
gefaltet dieser ganze juice in die Mitte
zusammen läuft wie du den ganzen Note
geben müsstest das steht da drauf 8,9
wow da ziemlich ziemlich gut es war eine
sehr sehr überraschend gute Pizza die
echt geil Geschmäcker und die Combo hat
funktioniert insgesamt bin ich sehr
zufrieden mit dem Bewertung von heute
danke dir dass du da warst Leute 10.000
Kalorien hätte ich auch nicht gedacht
dass wir das mal auf meinem Channel
machen da und äh ist kurz ich wollte mal
wissen was war dein Lieblingsgericht
heute werden zwei Gerichte dabei die du
selber noch nie gemacht hast ganz klare
Sache French Toast echt er hat mich übel
werde ich auch definitiv noch mal machen
der war next level krass ja wir sehen
uns beim nächsten Video wieder schaut
unbedingt bei Franklin vorbei dann seht
ihr wie wir einen Tag lang das Essen
getauscht haben und bis zum nächsten Mal
haut rein ciao